tourism since the collapse of the soviet
union and its consequences abroad and at
home
watch at 10 am and 3 pm eastern only on
book tv on c-span 2.
david france covered the crisis in the
catholic church as a senior editor at
newsweek next he chronicles 40 years of
sexual abuse in discussing his new book
our fathers this talk from the harvard
coupe in cambridge massachusetts lasts
about an hour
well i guess we're ready to begin so uh
good evening everyone welcome to the
coop
you know boston may uh take the leap in
higher education technology these days
but when it comes to scandals other
cities i think are far more cutting edge
now they after all have their corporate
frauds and their insider trading
their cooked books and their enrons and
their dot-com expose
but boston is an old and old-fashioned
town gentrification notwithstanding
and it draws its scandals from a very
old well
we deal here still
in the timeless themes that uh when you
see them on the movie screen in for
instance mystic river
have the critics dusting off the
adjective shakespearean
but what's shakespearean to others is
just bostonian to us
now all of you i'm sure know the themes
as well as i do
tribal bonds and tribal feuds
trust betrayed faith misplaced
fraternal strife authority abused and
law perverted
the daily dramas
compromises and complicities of precinct
ward and parish
now ken lay may be the bland face of
contemporary miscreancy elsewhere in the
country
for us it's james whitey bulger and
pedophile priests
well we certainly have exclusive rights
to the fbi and whitey saga
and while boston true is but one among
many cities touched and devastated by
the recent church scandals
we may be forgiven i hope for thinking
it peculiarly our own
now ever since concord and lexington
began the revolution
we are used to being first in everything
except the american league
and the scandal's first bomb burst in
this archdiocese
it started here and it still hasn't
stopped
we did not pass the scandal's baton
along to others and let it go at that
and we did not i think in the babel talk
of pop therapy reach any closure
it is a nightmare from which boston is
still trying to wake
and live bombs might still be waiting in
the scandal's ruins
and exploded years from now
now in general a certain time has to
pass for the smoke of great and
and terrible events to claire and
historians and journalists
to be able to see the uh the forest as a
whole not just the individual trees and
to put these events into perspective for
the rest of us
and enough time surprisingly has already
passed
for tonight's guest senior newsweek
editor david france
to offer us a bombshell of his own our
fathers
an earlier boston crisis school busing
resulted years later in a now classic
book whose depth more than matched and
justified its heft
that book of course was common ground
no less vast
no less fascinatingly cast
no less dramatic in events are
novelistic in the telling
and surely no less revealing of its
subject the secret life of the church
and its effects on the soul of a
community
our fathers is this year's common ground
it is both a chronicle of what happened
giving coherence to the scandal's jigsaw
fragments and scattershot revelations
and an investigation into why it
happened
it digs deep
sees far and ranges very wide
as infinite as boston's own variety may
be
this city alone cannot contain the whole
story
and so david leads us circle by widening
circle
from the local scene to the national
and ultimately to the holy see
as a scandal's polluted and polluting
tide rises to the feet of the pope
himself
it is a story written in ink and fire
both
the kind that blurb writers promise will
keep you reading through the night
trite hype though that may be in this
case it's really true
on behalf of the harvard coupe therefore
it is a great pleasure to produce
presents
david france
[Applause]
it's a wonderful introduction thank you
very much
i've come to the project of trying to
chronicle the uh
long history of abuse within the
catholic church as an outsider an
outsider to boston and outsider to
catholicism
and i settled upon a methodology really
for how to to uh begin my work
to
create a road map for myself for how to
follow through on this project and i
modeled my efforts after the truth and
reconciliation commissions that had been
established after other
long sad histories
in
places like south africa and chile
guatemala
argentina and i felt that by using this
method it would allowed me to
to
invite
people to tell me their stories
in a way that accepted their stories as
truth
and allowed me to stand away from it and
just record those stories
it also allowed me to approach people
from all sides of the divide that
produced this scandal in this crisis in
the church
from
the innocent
kids who had been assaulted often
repeatedly by their priests
to the priests themselves
most of whom
did what they could to be decent and and
moral priests and leaders in their
community
including however priests who molested
kids
who
at the end of their long journey were
able to share their stories with me and
their understandings with me about why
they felt they did what they did and
what they thought was motivating them
um
as well as in some instances their
journey to
to toward penance toward an effort to uh
seek forgiveness and to seek
kind of a more moral life and and kind
of a sounder psychological future
to the lawyers involved in all aspects
of the case i've taken all these stories
and tried to braid them together
over the course of this period of abuse
i
it allowed me also invited me actually
to go and consider that the individuals
who i was writing about had begun their
journey
through the crisis all of them as
innocence in a way and it encouraged me
to look at even people like cardinal law
here in boston and the and the grotesque
number of priests who abused children
here and and young adults and to to
assume just for a moment
that they didn't enter the priesthood to
do that that in fact they entered the
priesthood
to do what you would imagine a person
would enter the priesthood to do which
is to serve their church to serve their
faith and to serve the the families and
especially the children in their
communities i wanted to find out
what had happened to them
what had caused them to behave in the
ways that they seemed to behave in
as well as what happened to the people
who they
destroyed by their activities the
families that they destroyed by their
activities and the communities that
once especially
the news broke in early 2002 here in
boston and then spread across the
country the entire communities that were
destroyed by this and the the community
of the catholic faithful who were made
to have to find a way to deal with this
these narratives and i've done it all in
narrative form
braid together in a sometimes clumsy and
sometimes
enormous way and what i've what i'm
going to try to do tonight is to pull
out a single narrative or two and try to
present those to you over time
so you get a sense of some of the
central themes that appear in the book
i should say that i'm reading about
a gentleman who's here tonight phil
saviano
who was the founder of the local
chapter of these uh
of snap the survivor's network for those
abused by priests he's in the national
leadership of the organization and it
was phil as you'll see through this
section that i'm reading
who um
eventually
was the person who broke the log jam
really he was the person who kept
hammering at
the local media here in the boston
market until he finally got some teeth
on the boston globe and sat with them
for
an interview the interview that brought
about the understanding on the part of
the reporters there that helped us
expose this problem i'm starting though
in the uh
i am starting in
december 17 1992
jamaica plain massachusetts
phil saviano's winter was like his
summer one week staggeringly identical
to the next an indistinct
procession of pills and blood draws and
news of the aids epidemics march through
america
over 200 000 dead now no cure in sight
he was a bit more robust robust than in
recent months
but he was a clear-eyed rationalist
he trained himself not to despair death
he felt was just another burden of life
he took it on like an unfulfilling job
on good days he meandered about town
visiting funeral parlors
shopping for a venue for his final
goodbye
today was a good day
since it seemed plain he would make it
till christmas he dressed and headed out
to do a little shopping very little
given the pittance of his social
security disability checks
he opened his door and bent for his
newspaper his eye fell in a name he had
not thought of in 20 years
father david hawley his parish priest
two new mexico catholics 128 the other
32 had filed suit alleging he had abused
them when they were small boys
saviano was incredulous he had nearly
forgotten holly who had arrived at his
neighborhood parish in east douglas an
hour west of boston when saviano was a
la exactly eleven and three quarters
years old
though in his thirties holly had the
agreeable personality of an adolescent
kid parents loved him the boys in ccd
class which met every friday afternoon
thought he was extremely cool
dropped into class often
when he tapped at the shoulder of this
boy or that one and asked him to stop by
the rectory afterward to give them help
give him help lifting boxes or moving
the flower arrangements they were quick
to agree usually in twos or threes and
they lingered afterwards to laugh at his
jokes and marvel at his card tricks
saviano remembered thriving on holly's
attention one day the cards that made
the tricks had pornographic pictures on
them
the discussion would lead to questions
about girls prying questions inquiries
about the boy's budding sexuality
inquiries made first with words and
shortly with hands
the boys had all struggled to escape but
were not allowed to until their bodies
had been pinched and sized up by the
priest sometimes he showed them his own
penis to their silent dismay
they shared this shocking
secret together unspoken but one
afternoon in the cool dank basement
below the church
holly found savio saviano apart from the
others
gripped his small body and forced the 12
year old boy to perform oral sex on him
holly was a big man with big hands
gripping on saviano's arms
the boy's mind raced but he could not
find a solution to his quandary other
than this
if he did what the priest wanted and got
it over with he could just go on his way
of the boys who had been groped really
of all the boys ever born he was sure he
was the only one required to perform
this act he sometimes wondered why he
returned to help the priest time and
again
abused each time
but he could not formulate an objection
a religious duress compelled him to do
what he was told
after taking his liberties which began
his regular became his regular habit
father holly never commanded young
saviano into secrecy he didn't threaten
to dispatch the boy to hell or remind
him who was more credible or pretend
that their liaison had been pr a private
sacrament or any of the other tricks the
other priests often used
he didn't need to express his authority
except through the clothing that he wore
which gave him the power to dominate and
exonerate him all at once
saviano knew that he not holly was
responsible for everything that happened
between them
starting with the priest's raw drives
and urges
on saturday afternoons he would kneel in
the rich confines of the confessional
and seek his absolution for having been
abused to please to plead for grace from
the one who had abused him
forgive me father i have sinned i yelled
at my mother i lied to my brother and
you know the rest
in 1965 between one sunday and the next
18 months into saviano's nightmare
father holly had vanished from his
parish without a word
their secret remained buried and all
these years until he stumbled upon the
story about new mexico and the two
youngsters who like him were plunged
into this world of darkness saviano had
not thought about holly again
he poured over poured over their story
it blew saviano's mind wide open of
course he wasn't the only one yes there
must have been others why had that
thought not occurred to him before
why had he thought he was the father's
only boy why had he felt so darkly
special so singularly and pathetically
vulnerable
desperate to reach the two young men
saviana called the boston globe reporter
who bylined the story stephen kirkchen
who agreed to put the man in
communication
though not without doing his best to pry
the local angle story out of saviano but
he wouldn't budge
going public was the last thing in the
world he wanted
he knew what he needed and that was the
camaraderie of another man who knew
holly as he did
when joseph hafferman came to the phone
however saviano was blindsided by a
surge of his own guilt if he had found a
way to stop father holly hafferman would
not be a victim today he thought
it happened to me too saviano said
sharing their histories both men saw the
similarities were sickening the
wrestling the card tricks
except huff hufferman was eight when the
pornographic cards made their first
appearance
saviano wanted to cry it was bad enough
for me 11 12 but eight
i called the worcester diocese to tell
them about holly the man from new mexico
said he's up in denver right now he's
probably still doing it to kids it
doesn't seem like anybody's keeping an
eye on him
did they tell you about his record here
they had not it just seemed to draw the
diocese it just seemed the diocese was
unwilling to take action at all
it's really important to people to
understand that he started molesting
kids here in massachusetts in the 60s
sabiana said clearly he was a very has a
very very long history
if it would help at all he said catching
even himself off guard
i would consider going public with my
story
that's a big decision said heiferman
that's up to you it's a very humiliating
event would going public make it more
humiliating or less humiliating well for
me it was less he said
when he hung up the phone saviano
wondered how how his life might have
might change if he were to call stephen
kirkchen back at the globe but before he
could fully imagine it the phone rang
again robert curtis an albuquerque
attorney had just heard from hafferman
he's my client curtis said but we have
something else in common
holly abused me too
saviano could not speak
we have an obligation to other children
to get holly off the streets curtis
continued we should have been protected
from holly as children but we weren't
there are few people in life who are
given the opportunity to make a
difference you have that opportunity
within a week phil saviano told his
story anonymously to steve kirkchin
then the speed of events accelerated
holly victims began to stream out of the
woodwork police
alamogorgdo new mexico
uh issued an arrest warrant but we're
told the priest had gone east to st luke
institute outside of bethesda maryland
the local sheriff attempted to make an
arrest twice they were told holly was
not there finally a team of officers
combed the campus anyway and found
father david holly cowering in a
stairwell
after the arrest saviano no longer felt
afraid to allow his name to be known he
was a man with little to lose
he agreed to tell everything every
intimate aspect of his abuse to the to
usa today
but there was one thing he did not
mention the fact that he had aids he was
sure that the diocese would use that to
discredit him gay guy dying of aids
who's going to believe this guy he
thought
and one thing he hadn't anticipated
they would want to photograph him the
problem was he looked like a gay
gay guy dying of aids the only solution
he could come up with was makeup
he slathered it all over his face but
when he crawled out of his car and he's
douglas to greet the photographer he
knew it was no use
he leaned up against the facade of the
old church decrepit and out of breath
and ruined
this goes forward
a year
may 1993 in worcester massachusetts
again phil saviano and three other new
england victims of father david holly
were in agreement they wanted the
western diocese to provide them with
whatever psychotherapy they might need
which given their traumatic childhoods
might be considerable
and they wanted to know just how bad a
guy this was
so they were asking that the diocese
opened up files on him
to the public
i should interrupt and say
uh
after holly was arrested he immediately
pleaded guilty and was threw himself on
the mercy of the court
which showed little mercy and sentenced
him to 275 years in prison
eric mcleish an attorney who had done
well with victims of an earlier priest
in the fall river diocese
agreed to represent them in negotiations
with the diocese of worcester he
interviewed the victims detailed their
allegations and letters to the bishop
and laid out their demands for financial
restitution
the holly group discussed the
possibility of suing rather than seeking
a settlement which eric mcleish proposed
saviano especially favored formal
litigation a public trial and jury
verdict he thought would harm the church
more than the money
despite the rising number of settlements
no one had ever actually filed a lawsuit
against the church in massachusetts
wanting to make no false step
saviano bought a book called everything
you wanted to know about civil cases
one by one his fellow survivors joined
him saviano knew it would be a difficult
road but he looked at the
bottle of second second all's in his
nightstand and this is a bottle a doctor
had given him earlier and in case he
felt like he could no longer
fight this
fight against hiv
he looked at the bottle of second all in
his nightstand and he thought thank god
i didn't take those yet
i have work to do
he went on to form the new england
chapter of snap
mcleish and his associates filed their
lawsuits naming the priest holly and the
worcester bishop timothy harrington whom
they alleged
was managerially negligent compounding
the problem
eventually the number of massachusetts
plaintiffs grew to four
saviano knew the community he grew up in
would close ranks he didn't anticipate
it would get violently confrontational
once word of the suit got out
anonymous phone callers warned him to
drop the case in a wildly scrawled facts
one parishioner wrote him you [ __ ]
ought to let go of the past and the
[ __ ] you all enjoyed
even his family especially his family
disapproved
his godparents his aunts and uncles his
siblings none of them ever mentioned the
public campaign
never offered their condolences for his
abuse once it became known
or their support for his suffering
for him the pain of their silence their
silent disavowal was excruciating he
felt ashamed
but phil's 74 year old father didn't
feel silence alone was enough to conf
can convey his rage
he and his wife phil's stepmother were
active in church affairs
phil's homosexuality had been a source
of embarrassment for them
they could not stand by now and watch
the church suffer the scandal of
publicly
surrounding their
surrounding their son's warfare
leave the church alone his father
screamed you've got one foot in the
grave and one foot on a banana peel i
can't imagine why why you're doing this
going forward now two more years
august 10th 1995.
phil's case against the worcester
bishop progressed in frustrating
increments two years had passed
church lawyers fought the litigants at
every turn
however in time for the in time the
litigants had forced the diocese to
produce enough internal memos to make it
plain how much they knew but didn't
address about father holly
the memo trail was indefensible holly
who was hospitalized repeatedly and once
ordered to undergo shock therapy
was the subject of repeated complaints
stating from his first assignment in
1962
when his own diocese tired of his
endless recidivism rather than sending
him to jail the presiding bishop wrote
of his efforts to find a benevolent
bishop who could use his services and
began peddling holly to diocese around
the country that's how he got
assignments in new mexico minnesota and
texas
where bishop joseph fiorenza noted in
his own records that he knew of the
priest's past but gave him faculties
anyway
with our shortage of priests he wrote
i'm willing to risk incarnating him
in saviado's mind the civil liability
extended to every parish in diocese
where holly had served and every
church-run facility that purported to
treat and cure him but the whole thing
suddenly became moot
saviano's aids-related pneumonia had
returned
and nothing he and his doctors did over
the summer could contain it
finally on a hot thursday in august his
breathing became so labored he could not
avoid hospitalization his condition was
grave
doctors discovered an additional problem
a real rare fungal infection in the
lungs
they put him on oxygen and antibiotics
so powerful as kidneys rebelled
it was not looking good as doctors said
but for the first time in the course of
his disease saviano knew with a profound
certainty that he was not ready to
depart
his battle with the church was only half
fought he wasn't ready to take the
secrets with him to the grave listen he
said remember a while ago i asked you
for the means to check out well i know
this is going to sound like a
contradiction but i don't want to do
that anymore i never did get around to
doing my deposition
i really want to have an opportunity to
get that all down in a legal document i
don't know how this is going to go here
for me
this time anyway with the pneumonia but
i'd like to do everything i'd like you
to do everything you can to keep me
alive
despite what i may have said
at least that is until i finish the
deposition
his lawyers pulled from to rally we're
going to take this to the end promised
joseph boyland the associate of eric
mcleishes who was handling the case i
want you to call me every day every
single day tell me what you're doing how
you're doing and if it looks like you're
getting any worse we'll do the
deposition right here in the hospital he
promised
luckily phil turned the corner and
eventually was discharged into nursing
care where saviano's lawyers presented
him with the best offer they could get
out of the church
a company as compensation for being
sexually molested by his priest for two
years and a lifetime of anger that
followed
saviano would get fifteen thousand five
hundred dollars
the church offered the same amount to
each of the holly litigants
their lawyers gave a strong endorsement
for them to sign so strong in fact that
zambiano felt that they were being given
an ultimatum sign on the dotted line or
find yourself another lawyer
saviano never cared about the money what
he was after was full disclosure
but he was also a pragmatist he knew his
future was not promising
he capitulated okay he said i'll sign
he would withdraw his suit in exchange
for fifteen thousand five hundred
dollars
enough after paying his debts he figured
for a simple burial
he had one proviso though he wanted the
diocese to acknowledge its terrible
errors it made
they wouldn't do it boiling predicted
and they didn't
on the day saviano was supposed to sign
his settlement agreement he felt
outflanked and re-victimized by the
whole legal ordeal regretful that he had
come forward in the first place but as
you as he was about to put his signature
on the form something else jumped off
the page at him in exchange for the
check
he was asked to accept a strict
confidentiality requirement
not only was he enjoined from mentioning
holly again
but if if he signed he would never be
able to say or write anything on any
subject that might bring in quotes
scandal embarrassment ridicule or the
like to the catholic church
he would have to quit snap one clause
even made it impossible for him to
discuss his sexual abuse history with
his therapists unless he had joined the
non-disclosure pact i can't sign this
you told boyland
i'm not going to keep their little
secrets for them
this is nothing unusual boyland argued
all the other clients had signed
i don't care saviana said if need be
i'll just walk away from it i filed this
suit because i wanted to know the whole
story of father holly to a certain
degree i got what i came for
i know now what happened
despite knowing his chances were minimal
boiling agreed to ask the diocese to
drop the confidentiality clause they
would not
with all due respect to your client
wrote frank puccio jr one of the
churches of church's attorneys
this is
there is absolutely no possibility that
i will agree to what your client has
requested
again saviano didn't care his answer was
unchanged it's mean he said
mean-spirited they just don't care about
the victims all they care about is
keeping this stuff a secret
by rejecting the offer he was told he
was putting the law firm in a position
to consider dumping him all together
their lawyers fees were a percentage of
the restitution not hourly rates they
were trial attorneys not social workers
or church militants
they didn't work for free they would not
go to trial
boylan stuck it out however exchanging
an occasional letter with the church
lawyers it would be another two years
before the diocese would agree to drop
the gag clause
perhaps assuaged by the litigant's
precarious health
however for his concession for this
concession they would demand that the
settlement offer be reduced from fifteen
thousand five hundred to twelve thousand
five hundred
unable to find a lawyer who'd take his
case to trial saviano had to accept
his share after lawyers fees and
expenses was five thousand four hundred
dollars
and
i'm not going to read the section about
how the story broke and it was this kind
of complicated interplay between uh
lawyers for the boston globe and the
fact that the boston globe luckily
landed a new
uh
editor-in-chief
um in late 2001
who who saw the possibility of suing the
church is not as frightening as previous
leaders of the paper had
um
and uh
action uh uh activism on the part of
many organizations and kind of a growing
understanding around the country that
suits were being filed against the
church and yet very little was known
about the system that produced these
kind of crimes
the case
was brought to light in early january
2002
in a startling series of stories in the
globe uh which sparked
similar journalism in cities across the
country um
within months there were some 700
reporters working on the story of the
catholic church crisis
and producing uh really a festival of
stories of
very similar just to fills of abuse
around the country and with a very
similar cover-up pattern
but finally the secrets were out
organizations like snap were growing
um new organizations were cropping up of
uh of kind of rebel catholics angry with
their church
and an entirely new dynamic had taken to
the streets
on june 23rd 2002
in boston
it was phil saviano's
50th birthday
he spent the morning of his 50th
birthday celebrating his lousy childhood
at a solidarity walk for victims of
sexual abuse
since the day father holly first raped
him and certainly since the crisis
exploded he had never felt the kind of
support and acceptance from catholics
that he felt this morning
they gathered at the corner of boston
common by the hundreds grandparents and
kids and strollers teenagers carrying
lawn chairs their lapels bearing purple
ribbons to symbolize suffering
sixty held large blown up blow-up
photographs of sexual abuse victims
taken at the time of their abuse
with music playing in the background
they paraded single file to the
cathedral a procession that took over an
hour as he drifted along with the crowd
saviano thought back on his supper the
night before
out of the blue an old boyfriend from
new york had called he'd lost touch with
saviano in the late 1970s but thought to
call him after coming across his name in
the new york times
he had traveled up to boston to buy him
a birthday dinner
these days he was married with two
children
his bisexual phase had not lasted long
but for him it had been memorable
he told saviano that he had been the
most beautiful man that he had ever
known as gentle and striking as the
statue of david
saviano was surprised by this assessment
how could he have been so stunning and
not have known anything about it
was this part of the holly effect
or was this because of the hiv infection
was his hiv infection part of the holly
effect
thinking back on it all he realized that
after their affair he had become more
and more a recluse by the year shying
away from real and lasting intimacy
for the past five years the only thing
he had done with any passion was
organizing snap meetings
he felt curiously free to ponder these
things now as he stood amid the hundreds
of supporters people who didn't blame
his abuse on him
reinforcements
people who were ready now to take on the
battle that had become the only thing in
his life
he began to imagine returning to the
workforce he began to imagine putting it
all behind him the abuse the aids the
rejection
just then a reporter from the diocesan
newspaper the pilot approached and asked
him how he felt about the event
this is a very powerful event he said
what he thought was
this is a first step to healing
that's all i'm going to read from the
book
i think
mostly we'll remember
what's happened since then
we know that some 500 priests have been
removed from parishes
because allegations multiple allegations
had existed against them we know that
the catholic church itself has gone into
kind of a seizure of crisis
ordinary catholics abandoning their
church
donations are downs closings of parishes
are on the rise
we know that there have been a number of
criminal prosecutions some very
prominent
a number of bishops who have
lost their jobs have stepped down some
have been convicted of crimes we now
know um the crisis isn't over
uh but for the first time i think we
have a possibility of
understanding the scope of what happened
and uh and and seeing if we can that it
never happened again
i want to open it up for questions and
or comments of any sort um from anybody
if you'd like to uh
contribute in any way
sir
yeah these were criminal acts are you
do you have any thoughts on why
they weren't dealt with
uh criminally as opposed to by lawyers
it seems to me that if it had been
dealt with by the police or the district
attorney or whoever does it it might
have been dealt with much earlier
and it might be more lasting
the um
well it sounds like the lawyers are
getting most of the money out of it it's
a very good question the um
the major problem that we've had in the
cases currently
is in bringing criminal charges is that
the church was so successful in a
uniform way in covering up the crimes
that for years nothing was done and in
many instances statutes of limitations
ran their course so we haven't been able
to see the kinds of criminal
prosecutions that we wanted to bring now
how was that system of cover-up enacted
in the 60s and 70s and 80s
that is a really important thing for us
to know there was a lot of complicity
we've now seen from
police officers who gave some deference
to the church
not because they thought that these guys
were any less criminal but because these
guys supervisors would go to the police
in many instances we've seen it
documented and say
i'm the bishop of this diocese
let me take care of it we are the
catholic church
you know let let us we promise we're
going to take care of this
and uh the cat the chaplain in the
police department or often the the
catholic police captain or police chief
would accept the veracity of that
statement and give them the opportunity
to do it there was also
the church relied on friendly newspapers
friendly catholic newspaper editors if
not friendly then at least
you know slightly bowed newspaper
editors who were as much
in awe of their church as the victims
themselves
same with judges same with you know
state law enforcement officials so there
was kind of a there was a willingness to
defer to the church that they really
allowed this to go on
the corruption of the criminal system
it seems to me if that's going on who
knows what else is going on in this case
we know that that was going on and we
know that the corruption really extended
in a way why isn't there a story about
that and oh there is and it's called our
fathers
you're not just talking about the
catholic church scandal you're talking
because you're talking as i see it it's
a scandal of the catholic church it
seems to me it's a scandal of the
criminal justice system i i think any
period that you look at you might be
able to find similar stories regarding
similar kind of power inversions but in
this instance what we had was a catholic
church that was very powerful in certain
cities in certain communities in the
country and every place they had a kind
of plurality of power they were able to
say that the church itself the
institutional church they were able to
convince enough of the civil authorities
that they were
that they were uh you know
uh
uh benevolent enough and and concerned
enough that they were a higher authority
that that no one had the power to bring
this priest to justice quite like the
supervisors in the church and you think
the statute of limitations covers a
cover-up also it seems to me that with a
cover-up that may void the statute of
limitations
it sometimes does and statutes of
limitations have um really interesting
clauses you know these are state laws
one of the clauses says that if you
leave the state
the statute goes on hold so let's say
the statute is 10 years a lot we've seen
in in the priest cases a priest will get
and father holly was one of these guys
gets shifted out of town to avoid you
know if it gets too hot that even the
police chief is going to say look we're
going to have to bring a charge against
this guy the bishop then and we've seen
the paperwork the bishop writes to
another bishop says you know you got to
take this guy because he's too much
trouble here and the other bishop takes
him you know active cover-up
so they leave town
leave the state and if they cross state
lines that statute stops
but only then have we been able to use
it in the case of priestly sexual abuse
and there's a good reason for that i
mean that the statue of limitations is
not supposed to protect people who
effectively hide
it's supposed to
limit the um
the amount of time it acknowledges how
how uh
that evidence
gets weaker over time that memory the
key evidence in a lot of sexual abuse
cases that memory itself is very
volatile and so in order to assure a
kind of a fair justice system the laws
set these limits different in each state
but
so you're right i mean that was
compounded in a way that was successful
they really got away with it and that's
what happened they really got away with
it
anybody else
oh surely there's more to talk about
yes
there are
issues surrounding uh
the
statute limitations that were presently
being
looked at by social science
professionals who understand that
memories uh surrounding this type of
abuse
don't
revisit until uh way beyond the state's
set mandatory or stashes of limitations
as a rule
uh so there are several bills in the
house in massachusetts right now that
are
that are
looking at those that are
trying to address them and
and change that because it's um
it's an important issue i mean part of
the
the problem with uh
having a catholic hierarchy
not willing to
discuss uh
any aspect of sexuality in in a in a
healthy way
in these instances in the past helped
create this ability this
you know hiding place
uh for for these crimes um but it's
important today to
to go
to the legislature and um support you
know analyze these bills there many of
them there are several out there but um
you make an important point that you
don't want to reward the people who
successfully get away with it and there
have i think there in many states across
the country there are efforts to to uh
to change the definition of a statute of
limitation to uh to in in california we
saw that they lifted at least for a
period of a year they said we are
lifting the statute of limitations in
sexual abuse cases
many arrests were made appeals were made
ultimately the supreme court and the
supreme court
um
you know codify recodified the notion of
a statute of limitations saying that
there's a reason that we have this as a
society and it's of imperfect reason and
and it creates all sorts of conflicts
um it's it's a big problem it's one of
the it's the one of the many legal
aspects that's being struggled on now to
try to come to grips with all the things
that we've learned about you know the
problems with religion the problems with
the criminal justice system as a result
of this crisis
church state uh
complicity that you that was spoken
about is is sort of arcane i mean it's
the way that we're looking at these
issues today about taking uh uh
words out of uh uh or prayer out of
schools and these type of uh you know
this uh
courthouse debacle down in louisiana or
i believe it was and this this is an age
where we're understanding that there's
the church has really stood in a way of
a real proper dialogue or proper
approach to uh
issues about
sexuality i've i've heard it argued that
one of the
kind of hidden problematic aspects
that's been
kind of kind of coming to the fore in
the crisis is
the violation of that church state
divide
by prosecutors who are crawling into the
church and kind of
wanting to root through their personnel
files or
we saw in the case of
phoenix arizona where actually some
aspects of managerial aspects of the
diocese were given up to the state
but i argue that that's not a violation
of the church of state divide it's the
recreation of it it's saying that the
church exists
not as a sexually abusing organization
not as an extra-legal organization it
has to exist within the confines of
civil law especially criminal law
and if it doesn't do that then um i mean
that's not what the the notion of the
free exercise of religion
was all about
yes sir
i agree with that
but i'm wondering whether there's
something wrong with this country where
everything is going bad i mean we had
enron
we had enviro i'm a chemical engineer we
had a big environmental thing movement
we had the civil rights movement the
iraq war
i don't think other countries have these
problems what is going on in this
country
from your point of view and your work on
newsweek right yeah you must see some of
these things does it look like
everything is unraveling who knows what
else is going to come up now
there's a kind of a millennial feel to
it i agree with you about that
um but
but it's happening not just in the
united states and i'll i'll use some
other words um parmalat
you know very similar problem but also
we see it
and i think that our we don't learn much
about this in the u.s media because
we're so provincial here but the
catholic church problem this very
scandal exists in most western states
most western countries that we know of
um you know any place there's been the
exercise of the free press in the last
two years we've seen you know
the same sort of expose there
ireland germany you know through europe
um
uh
but we've also seen it in the third
world we've seen it in latin america we
see right now in the philippines which
is um you know in real turmoil over this
very question we've seen
it and it may vary the abuse patterns
may vary the cover-up patterns may vary
but the the system itself the system of
kind of these
so these uh celibate priests behaving in
non-celibate
non-consenting ways
with
minors or um or adults who you know try
to to to avoid this but are unable to
because of this kind of religious duress
we've seen its uniform
but it's an interesting point like why
now why are we seeing it now you know i
went back in history to earlier episodes
what seemed to be earlier episodes of
priestly sexual misconduct of this sort
and i went back through a series of
analyses of canon law dating back to the
year
177
and every 600 years or
1200 years there there are you know a
new series of laws promulgated
by
the vatican opposing
pedophilia or sodomy which was taken to
mean at the time taken to mean uh sexual
assaults on children
i don't think that was the last time but
that was certainly a big time yeah it
was certainly one of the times and um
but you know they wouldn't be
promulgating those laws if they didn't
if they hadn't recognized that they were
having a problem with
church the it society seems to be
every el i can't think of any element
that isn't subject how about education
is that going to turn out to be i mean
it's not just bad but is it maybe going
to be turned out to be corrupt well
maybe we could look at it this way maybe
these things go on always and maybe
every once in a while we get fed up with
it maybe this is one of those times okay
any idea why um
nope
do you have an idea
i have an idea about
may i introduce you
phil saviano everybody
i have an idea about why this issue
became so prominent in the last 10 or 12
years and i'd like to give a lot of
credit to tv programs like
phil donahue
in the oprah winfrey show who made it
acceptable for people to talk about
their traumatic childhoods and their
deepest darkest secrets and try to
figure a way to
heal from whatever that trauma did to
them emotionally
it's also worth pointing out that the
first
nationally broadcast tv program about
this issue was phil donahue who did a
show with jason berry
on the gilbert golf a case down in
louisiana back in 1988
and here in boston channel 5 refused to
broadcast it because they thought it was
too controversial and they didn't want
to broadcast something that's going to
take a shot they ordinarily syndicated
the show but they dropped this one
program it was listed in the tv guide
and it never aired but finally in early
1993 donahue did another show and then
oprah picked up on it and i think that
that was that you know that gave us a
lot of us myself included some courage
to feel that maybe we can go forward
with this
the other thing that happened and you
know maybe five or six years ago is the
advent of the internet
which from snap's point of view made it
so much easier for us to get our message
out to survivors and for survivors to
find us and in turn for us to be able to
connect them with the news media
and uh i think that if it hadn't been
for the internet in late 2001 and
throughout 2002
this might have had a much different
sort of outcome
certainly in boston the issue would have
exploded but i don't know that it would
have exploded in quite the same way in
other parts of the country because
without survivors being able to connect
with us being able to connect with the
news media
it wouldn't have been the same
so that's my that makes a lot of sense
you know while there were all these
reporters working on the story they
didn't know where to find their human
interest stories and if it weren't for
for you know people from
survivors organizations going to
reporters presenting themselves to
newspapers those stories wouldn't have
happened
they would have had no way to find them
because
cases unlike
unlike phil's cases that had been
settled
were
across the country subjected to these
gag orders the paperwork that had been
produced as part of discovery
depositions internal records any sort of
documentation had been impounded by the
courts
often we found lawyers who said not only
that but the lawyers were required to
give every xerox copy that they had ever
gathered put those in boxes and return
them to the church and sign statements
saying that they kept no scrap of
anything i mean there was a total
vacuuming back up of the document trail
so there was just nothing for reporters
to find except you know suspicion if it
weren't for you know this kind of
movement
which i see was connected by the
internet
um kind of coming to the bringing
themselves to the attention of the
journalists
um
i want to say that
practically everyone it's clear that the
way the hierarchy of the church handled
this thing was a disgrace and anyone
who's gone through the paper trail you
know was
just going to be horrified when you see
those things
but
there there is a current of
of
criticism of the media that's out there
um sometimes we hear from ray flynn who
was ambassador to the vatican locally
but nationally of the sociologist
jenkins at penn state and he argues that
clergy
sexual misconduct and abuse
is comparable in protestantism as it is
in catholicism the boston globe did a
piece denying that saying that there's
almost no incidents among protestant
clergy but i did recall reading an la
times piece which seemed to indicate
that there was a lot of clerical abuse
among protestants
and so i've seen among especially
conservative publications while they're
outraged by some of this misconduct
they also have a very anti-gay agenda
that they're blaming this on obviously
but they're also saying that they feel
the catholic church is being singled out
and i'm wondering what you have to say
if you have any thoughts about that the
catholic church itself through the
bishops conference uh here in this
country and
and through the vatican
still says that still believes that
they've been unfairly charged and unfit
and and they've been denied credit for
all the great things that they've done
um the latest thing is this report
that's due out next week but which we
saw leaked in cnn earlier this week
that you know purports to take a
cross-the-board assessment of how many
abusive priests they have and to show
the incidence rates among the priests
and they say look we're the only uh
vocation that's ever done this we're the
only industry that's ever surveyed our
people to find out you know how many are
each other and we call upon everybody
else to do it we call upon law
enforcement to do what we call and you
know
the the truth is that they if you
marshal the numbers
uh the way the catholic church is trying
to marshal the numbers now it doesn't
seem like it's a bad problem
four percent they seem to be arguing and
the uh
uh
incidence rates for uh childhood for
abuse
how do i put this the incidence rates
for adults who abuse children is in the
general population is three or four
percent it's about in that range so
they're trying to argue that they're
about in that range
but they're doing several things that we
know of and one thing that we assume the
one thing we assume is they're not
telling us the whole story
um and the two things that we know that
they're doing is that they're um
that they're using
uh all figures that they've gathered
from 1950 to 2002 or 2001 wherever their
cutoff is and but they're ignoring
the
the main incidents period which
uh from my research is a generation of
priests ordained in 1960 until about 19
late 60s early 70s that that generation
of priests had particular problems
now the the institution itself that
cover them up still exists in the very
same way so the that system of abuse is
still in place and still needs to be
torn down but the abuse itself the
incidence rates of the abuse are the
highest in this
bell curve the class of 1960 for example
here in the boston seminary 12 percent
um uh in the three
dioceses around the country where under
the threat of law enforcement
diocese have re
released their documentation on their
priests
and that means not just voluntarily but
they would you know be in real trouble
if they tried to hold any of it back the
figures are much higher they're you know
six percent six and a half percent um
eight percent seven point seven percent
in manchester new hampshire so these are
elevated incidence rates way over the
national average even when we include
the larger number of decades but if we
just go to that mid mid period and
follow the careers of those guys we see
an elevated rate
i think the reason for that is very
complicated which is why the book is
very long
but um i argue that it does that
in that generation in that religion
in that institution we have a problem
that's never been seen
in other certainly not in other
religions and not in any other
institution that we know of a real
elevation of uh psychosexually
dysfunctional adult priests an
institution that encourages them in a
way and and enables them
and a body of a ready and replenishing
body of victims
it seems that in the catholic
church in that tier of um responsibility
that there seems to be this whole
mysticism about who can say what and i
think that has led to some of that
um silence with regard to incidents of
abuse in the catholic church but i don't
think that it's any greater than in any
other
religion per se
because you do hear of incidents and
when you look at the incidence of abuse
in the in the larger population then
that does suggest that it's not only in
the catholic church but i want to also
ask
because i never hear anyone mention this
element of responsibility
as i hear about all the incidents of
abuse in the catholic church i always go
back to
where were the parents why did the
parents entrust so much of
their
responsibility given over to another
individual whether they perceive them as
somebody who they could trust or not
because i i've always felt as a parent
and even when i was younger and i when
you think about as memories begin to
surface from your own childhood that i
don't think that my parents i was raised
by my grandmother
even though there were people that she
entrusted me with there was i never felt
as a child that she was giving so much
trust into others it's a very important
part i was with that she would not
i understand it was a very important
point and that's one of the things that
i i had to ask over and over like how
did the parents respond to this did they
know should they have known and when
they knew
what did they do
and at the beginning of the talk i said
that i took this as this thesis that um
that people were trying had entered
this crisis period with an effort to be
moral with an effort to be good
and to comport themselves properly and i
wanted to find
how it was that the parents had
when they had had derailed you know when
when they made decisions if they did
consciously or unconsciously that that
they were going to either side with the
church or side with their children and
those i think are the most desperately
torturous
parts of this realization
in this narrative of the story that i
came up with because the tearing the
tearing but that that that i heard about
and learned about that mothers felt when
they were being really pulled from
by their church torn
aggressively by their church into
distancing themselves from their
children and just heartbreaking
absolutely
not anymore i'm sorry
okay lisa i just wanted to ask um when
you have the
statistics on the number of abusive
priests what about counting the number
of victims because i think that's a
number that really is hair raising now
this is um
this is also a number in great dispute
the um the report that's been leaked out
that said there were four percent there
was a four percent um incidence rate
um also of priests also says that they
that those priests and they came up with
a number 4
450 priests across the country that they
had abused 11 000 children in the course
of this period which which is an
atrocious number it's an unacceptable
number um and you know just it's it's on
an unimaginable number
um and it's also a number that nobody
believes
the
it's it's an impossible number to accept
because
we know of of so many
uh well let me put it this way snap as
an organization has
4 500 members now i think
so that would imply that half of the
people who had ever been sexually abused
by priests are you know have become
activists and have joined activist
organizations a kind of an unlikely
conclusion
but even more importantly uh the
catholic church commissioned a study an
internal study for for internal eyes
only in 1985
conducted by father
tom doyle who was at the time working as
a canon law attache to the vatican
embassy in washington
and he surveyed surveyed diocese across
the country in 1985 and developed
through extrapolation the number one
hundred thousand
for part of me
now this or was he using grealy's
numbers for that but the number the
number was a hundred thousand a hundred
thousand
and that was not a number meant for
public consumption that was a number for
them to come to some sort of you know
true um
and uh you know eye-opening realization
about the problems that they experience
um
now while they're they're busy you know
spinning and trying to tell us that
they're doing the right thing and
they're opening their books and their uh
and they're telling us the truth the
numbers drop down to a really low number
and
there are very few people who are
accepting it
um and the the media has called it
shocking and i think it's true it is
shocking even if it were 11 000
that would just be you know it would be
you know indefensible
but i think it's probably 10 times that
my name is bart um i just want to say a
few words i'm a catholic
and um i heard in the news how the kids
god did get abused
by the father in brighton
and i feel very strong about that in the
catholic
organization
that
children had rights
to not to be abused by a priest
and that's my word
i don't know about anybody else but i
don't think you find too many people who
would disagree with you on that
but thank you for sharing
yes sir
the number of uh of people
in the general population have been
abused
because you can do a lot of things with
numbers but i but
i think the uh
there's a criminal justice institute in
located somewhere in western mass that
came up with a one in three women by the
time they're 18
one and uh about four what is it one in
five men by the time they're 18. suffer
some form of sexual abuse by the time
they're 18 uh could be
you know uh
some instance where someone berates you
or you know with words but those are
that's those are the numbers and sexual
abuse is very prominent and there are a
whole lot yeah and the the thinking is
that there are a lot of problems that's
come off of it those numbers are pretty
outrageous right there so
there's a lot of problems that that stem
from the abuse
that end up being
caught by institutions like prisons
uh
substances like alcohol and drugs
and it's a huge it just is a huge social
problem generally so it's something that
uh you know obviously i mean children
got it and it's something we don't know
much about and because you you were
right to point out that the statistics
are you know suspect we don't know um
the surveys across the country vary
wildly on sexual abuse histories
we don't know why that is we should have
a much better data set on all of that
but we do know that it's very very uh
problematic in in this country in that
many people
if not a plurality have suffered some
sort of really awful sexual violations
in their childhood and um
and we don't you know we've developed
policies we've developed the you know
the safe touch programs we've developed
you know kind of a much better
understanding now than we had in 1985
which was much better than we had in
1965 which was non-existent
but but still we don't really know what
it means
we have no
real research about no no
neurobiological research on the impact
of sexual abuse we've got a lot of kind
of clinical observations there's so much
more we need to know about it we know
it's not good
we know that it can often be disastrous
but the whole parameters of that
discussion are really yet to have kind
of unfolded for us
if anyone has one
the
bishops who were in charge of the
diocese
apparently
charged with
blindness or malice
but they weren't the same bishops in
1965
say as are today
do you or do you or have you seen any
evidence of how the attitude of the
bishops has changed or has it
that's that's a very good question and i
wish there were an answer for it that
was um you know somehow fulfilling
we the the bishops have
remained in the church
that they took over and in a way we i
think we haven't really reached them
i think that we haven't seen evidence
that they've that they've changed course
that they've really understood
that what they did was wrong
many of the bishops in
in uh power now
i think two-thirds of them by one study
were
did have a role in moving abusive
priests to other parishes did have a
role in the cover-up that's two-thirds
of the current kind of bishop
class in this country
they have
pledged themselves to you know
these various reports which are
all self-reporting reports they haven't
opened up any files for any kind of
forensic examination they've pledged
themselves to do better they've promised
that they get it but we'd like to see
that they got it and you know when
cardinal law was forced to step down
here they went to the one bishop in
america that's
that's
that seems to be trusted by the people
to come and make the right decisions and
the right moves and you've got to ask
yourself with 195
diocese in america why there's only one
bishop who's called upon to ever take
over diocese where there have been such
troubles there should be you know 195
leaders that see that
that what the catholic church needs to
be is a church that responds to the
suffering of kids
and protects kids from future suffering
you know
certainly they know that it's dangerous
if they mess up again but has have they
moved their hearts to the right place i
don't know that we've seen the evidence
of that yet
thank you all for coming i appreciate
your questions
[Applause]
david france is author of our fathers
the secret life of the catholic church
in an age of scandal it's published by
broadway books on the web at
broadwaybooks.com
you